okay complete this iconic line this is
my favorite line okay never been set on
television and I'm putting this out here
I want to forgive you and I want to
forget you
yes and then for bonus points key to an
impression of Lauren doing that oh man I
can never put that face on my face
this was the times I'm Heidi I want to
forgive you forget you that was cutting
very cutting it was like having Lauren
my hair we've got a trivia game for you
today cool are you ready yeah let you
study it's called the og bad boy quiz so
question number one mm-hmm where this
your line oh boy
by pushing me away you dr. dark I
remember this you push me into somebody
else crap ding ding ding ding ding do
you remember when that was said yeah I
think it was with Audrina when I started
to hang out with Kristin
okay finish this line Oh Justin Bobby
dot dot dot
I want to say something about my two
names but I don't think that right I
would say I've been hearing a man so
great they need to time through so bad
is it ha ha I mean do you get the other
name on the shirt and soon as it's so
great yes ideal
what did homeboy wear to the beach
you laughing why you laughing Justin go
a classic babe yes correct
do you think that's my winning three
four three red you're gonna win like I
think it's just pie
who is the sentence about he's such a
sucky person
correct Heidi said that mmm Heidi said
yeah really it what are the first words
Lauren says on the hills ever ever look
at me it's like the most simple thing
ever it's hi I'm Tommy
descripton yeah yeah what UK reality TV
show is Stephanie join it's a classic
British TV new details from Rex this is
the final question or good are you ready
[Laughter]
what did you know so they got less PG at
the house now I'm probably gonna go very
rare okay complete this iconic line this
is my favorite line okay ever been said
on television and I'm putting this out
here I want to forgive you and I want to
forget you yes and then put bonus points
can't you an impression of Lauren doing
that
the times I behind a and she's like
issue I want to forgive you that was
cutting very cutting it was like having
Lauren right here and just couldn't push
out a tear and it's not level if I leave
every great skills to have the wedge
thank you so much you killed that
congratulations